what's happening there witcher fans we
are here to watch the episode three of
season two yeah yeah i know my least
favorite part is doing the intros as
well you want us to hurry it up we'll
hurry it up hit the like button that's
the quickest way to get past this whole
process subscribe and click that
notification about full length watch
long as we stick over the time for which
are over our patreon page blah blah blah
covers so many shows over there at the
same time you get the actual reaction
highlights and watch songs included
we've heard this before correct oh and
why aren't you doing it last but not
least to the boys over at prepper they
rock i'm not going to skip over that
moment of silence
okay
[Music]
wish carol was my daddy
siri
you are savior he made his choice
cost us a brother
that wasn't our brother not by the end
of it and bitterness won't help us find
what killed him
oh i know what killed him leave it alone
no
you guys have to stick together last i
checked
we come here to rest in the winter and
to restore
and to have some fun
not train till our legs give out
training is fun
fine one more hour
then you can hang what's left of me on
the medallion tree
funny you should mention that
oh
you would have found it by now we've got
a lab full of alchemical compounds that
can change day to [ __ ] night i'm not
going to give up now but it's time to
escalate
he deserves the peace
nah they should find out what's going on
[Music]
oh my god how handy would that be
[Music]
he seemed to mourn a little bit harder
for her than everyone else
elves are not our enemies they've
already aligned with nilfgaard proving
what many of us have known for centuries
they cannot be trusted
why should they trust you
we'll be burying a lot more than 14
mages then 13.
oh
i care less about those others
it does seem that way doesn't it just
like you were at sodden you did what you
had to do
and i for one will always be grateful
for your sacrifice
did you know she would end up this way
maybe jennifer did ruefully laugh
huh i'm not little and i'm not afraid
it's easy to say bar road is a dark one
full of dangers
is that what you want i want
to do what a witcher does
[Music]
come on then
that was
really unnecessary yeah dude we're gonna
have to replace that now
it's just like american ninja warrior
yeah
caramora ninja warrior
oh yeah
still want to be a witcher
this is all it takes to be a witcher
just cross that all you got to do is
complete this one obstacle course
[Music]
now you can rest
damn these guys are like children of
esmere
literally
everybody stabbed me remember you got
that worm in your ears speaking of which
can we inspect your head
surely the savior of sodom would know
how to heat a pool
huh
what's with all this cutting away from
the nudity yeah guys jeez jeez i know
you wouldn't be in the youtube cut but
include us boys come on
malcolm was quarter elvin just as
jennifer's so what are you saying
jennifer's related to falca of course
not a historian should know bloodlines
better
no i remember
and all the mages in it her violence
etched here
fiber
whoa
how do we know that's not an illusion
you've been lied to us by your hands
this whole time what else don't you have
on your body
[Laughter]
the only certainty on this continent my
boy is that no one is ever what they see
sexist
[Music]
just hate women man
come on siri
let's go back
you're bad enough
also you and i found enough
[Music]
hey
well done
let's grab the top i would not
ride it around
ouch
god
oh
yeah
yeah sharp wood nice try princess
admit it you belong in a castle
no okay
oh even he's like you're being really
mean man
[Laughter]
yeah i'm sure you guys just excelled
your first time around
so sorry
heroes don't go mysteriously missing for
a month after battle you know it's
telling that you don't understand such
complex concepts as prisoners of war
sir you ran the company of nilfgaard oh
god this guy's such an [ __ ] if you
don't want to chat about your true
intentions aren't you forced to use a
method you're here to say his grandson
found off oh no
no no no no no no
[Music]
[Music]
that's more like it
stop oh
hell yeah i love them judy
again
stop showing off steady your legs and
breathe damage oh now he's teaching her
it's amazing
i love it
i love it
whoa nice
ah girl you're so cool
just shows up like let's see how this
goes
[Music]
[Applause]
almost perfect landing go again
so close
[Laughter]
oh they're the best
father-daughter team of the year trying
every herb every potion every spell
to get back what i have what i deserve
tell me how to save
i myself believe you
oh
from the moment we met you have been
trying to fill a void
power couldn't do it even when you had
it at your fingertips what makes you
think it's the answer now because it's
all i have left
toby mcguire was the exact same position
as spider-man
just got to get your groove back yeah
just recuperating now take on this
i want to be a great fighter and not
just against sacks of straw
you gotta master the foundations first
god damn it you gotta pace yourself
i have known many who wanted to be great
fighters in my time
do you know where they are now
greatly [ __ ] doing a battle somewhere
cemeteries
a book on how to be a dad
so your kid wants to be a winner
[Music]
is that pieces of this full
here we go
you keep looking down
that's why you're losing your balance
your enemies
aren't on the ground
they found a new hobby
they're so bored like oh thank god
that strange feeling that you get like
someone's coming after you when you
think about it what's the first word
that comes into your mind
a poem
it's like i'm being pulled
pulled towards what
i don't know
i'm cohen's checked out
boring
[Laughter]
if you were to follow that feeling
i would take you
what
it's missing a hand it's eskel slashy
oh
no
there it is
what
run
this was a bad idea
oh
oh
that is disgusting it's like a stick bug
in a centipede at a baby in hell
what is this thing
it looks so mutated
it's the thing
that's got to be some kind of mutant so
many manufacturing monsters again
[Music]
i wonder if he had her first power's
gonna kick him even more fire than
before
his head will be sent to sintra to make
our voices heard
this
is what strength looks like
ah displays a strength man be wary
[Applause]
what if you mess up on the axe okay
oh i got a shoulder shank
[Music]
damn
bird at all
it's a bit hot
burn it to the ground
get on her back man
why save me
don't flatter yourself
i'm saving me
i never respected you jennifer
[Music]
cool damn exactly like how i predicted
getting an end
didn't miss a beat
no that's what we call you you're just
the witcher beat cheetah
yeah so predictable this show every time
we sit down rig's like here's how it's
gonna go
hey now that was great that's a good one
that's a great episode everything was
firing in all cylinders
yeah wildfire like
so it sucks man jennifer's never gonna
get her powers back ever again no
there's no way there's no way the show
would never do that no no no actually
she respected the show dude she actually
never got the powers you know i was
thinking about that in the middle of
this episode when in the bath scene i
was like you know that would be a pretty
hard challenge for a character to
persist and to really take that message
to heart of you know in losing what you
think is your greatest asset perhaps you
can unlock your greatest strength well i
think what makes jennifer such a strong
character was never really her magic
if you're nothing without the suit
nothing without your boobs
i don't deserve to have no no no
you guys know what i'm getting at
something about like who she is
internally you know and the struggles or
whatever her mind and her resilience and
her cunning yeah
all fancy words
we are the men of our two mothers
welcome to reviews with guys
yeah no she's such a brilliant actress
now every storyline is just really
strong here i loved everything with siri
and geralt that was probably my favorite
part of this whole episode
well i love the way they did the
juxtaposition
when
oh god what's his name cohen and lambert
is the other guy lambert is the other
guy so yeah
lando i forget i'm gonna call him
lambert from now on you guys can yell at
me in the comments
but of how they are they're so opposing
towards
siri being here and they pretty much put
her up on the obstacle course
to taunt her and put her down and say
like i'm going to show you that you're
not worthy of being here and then they
do like a little time jumping they're
like no you're doing it wrong you gotta
tell everyone coaching her they're all
cheering her on you know and she's
winning over their respect with her
resilience i think it was such a
such a cathartic moment and what would
he do root for her and i think the way
they flesh out the relationship with
geralt and her
is
you know like you i'd expecting like any
other show for like father figure to
show up and be like what are you doing
get that from there you know something
like that deliberately
but he just shows up
stoic and observing and just all right
let's watch the hell he says it's so
close
so brilliant
i think the way they they do that and
like anything with like snowy landscapes
and me feeling the weather and
environment i think is really
really strong stuff so yeah i think that
is that that to me is my favorite part
of getting to live here
and um
like oh my god cash carve karma care
more care more india you know living in
karamorin and see their lifestyle and
bessemer of really a much more
because all we have to go off of
vessemer's background is nightmare of
the wolves so
you know seeing how he was sort of
indoctrinated into the witcher lifestyle
and a little it seemed he seemed to be
at a different age where he can be a
little bit more human than the other
ones yeah well if anything geralt's
actually
abnormally more stoic than the other
ones yeah well yeah if i'm remembering
correctly it's like you know vesimir
came up in the the old wave of the
pictures and then at the transition
point there where he's got to basically
be dad to the remaining few he's like
we're gonna do things
different yeah
we're watching him cry over eskel's
death and uh having to mourn him the
loss of that and how much is driving him
nuts
and also you know leading to the the the
lesh slushy fleshy
yeah leading to the leshi the lychee
which is crazy you see the tree the tree
thing and then you're like oh and then
oh crazy centipede
i love that too it's just like a nice
little trapping of the world of like oh
man you think you've got one problem on
your hands wait till this bigger problem
comes and eats it up in front of you
so
so well done but the yennefer stuff john
take it away oh man jennifer's is
suffering right now i mean
i'm curious as to how they're gonna
handle her return to magic because i'm i
have to imagine that's the choice they
will make but i like that at least we
have
this one episode to really sit within
that and to kind of bounce it off of
everybody else they're the remaining
mages who did make it through the battle
who were there who all have their
different battle scars or whatever and
and just watching i loved the
what was underneath the surface of her
performance because so much of her
performance in this episode has to be
played that way because she doesn't want
to admit the truth and accept the truth
for herself yeah and i mean continuing
on with like her and to say his
relationship is there's there's so much
that's
unspoken even though more has spoken
than ever before in terms of tesaya's
connection to her and her care for her
and i feel like there's still a lot more
to unpack in terms of like
where that comes from because to say it
clearly
sees a lot of herself in yen and she
clearly has
a bond very special and distinct to her
and so yeah watching
her position in this whole political uh
you know disarray and watching as you've
got guys like strigabor and all of them
you know casting doubt and trying to you
know maintain their seats of power like
they've done a really nice job of
drawing a personal struggle that's also
deeply intertwined with a bunch of
political
mayhem and yeah i i really
appreciate where it ultimately winds up
because even though yeah it's not
necessarily her accepting and having to
deal with her loss of magic it is a big
event that you cannot turn back like now
there's no returning to uh uh aratuza
and the rest of them you know and i and
i bet that'll lead to more uh you know
moments with istred in the future but
just the whole build up to her
you know slicing the chain and letting
kahir free uh i really like the debate
they drew around that and just the
doubts of you know spending all this
time
with the aftermath of uh of sadden and
everyone in eratusa and sort of figuring
out yeah what is the best plan of action
for yen
and uh it seems like i get like i'm
getting the sense that part of the point
of this season is to look at both
nilfgaard and the elves and the
brotherhood and be like okay
you know we come up in the perspective
of one through this character so we're
inclined to believe in the brotherhood
and characters like uh venga venga venga
hertz
vengo venga
vincent baker i know i've known his name
the entire episode and now it's foggy
but like you know guy vilgefortz there
you go yeah vilga ford's it to say like
you know we we like them especially
teseo but it seems like now they might
be casting that doubt of
what if the people who are siding with
nilfgaard are right and what if
nilfgaard's goal is actually just to
feed and clothe like i feel like that's
a dubious prospect because a lot of
tyrants would love you to believe that
line of reasoning but at the same time
i'm curious as to maybe because they've
drawn nilfgaard and company as such
villains up until now maybe they are
going to do that we're like hey we've
been on the wrong side this whole time
but i don't know man no no of course
they seem to cast people who played
villainous that's true right down to
this that's true right down to our
little prisoner here i know but even
he's more interesting now than than
before he still comes across quite evil
yes yeah but i don't know i feel like
they could be and this is just my own
you know interpretation but i feel like
they could be
uh playing off of that
some you know because though there is a
lot of mistrust between these people so
why would you be
uh as vulnerable or personable towards
somebody who you view as your captor and
your enemy and someone who wants to
destroy your way of life you know
i mean even in the scenes where he
wasn't held captive he was still kind of
messed up
although he did seem like when he was
trying to attain siri that he was
actually trying to help her in some way
before he got into a fight with his with
the doppelganger guy yeah or the uh
shape-shifter guy yeah he did seem like
it i'm trying not trying to help you and
i'm trying to help you realize what you
have within you yeah
i don't know both sides seem bad i think
that's the whole point of the show yeah
everybody pulling the strings is bad and
there's a bunch of good people trying to
make it work underneath them because
aratuza as much as that was where
jennifer was you know her origin tale
lies so much within there
every time we cut it that's like she
never
like she's the hero of sodon and then
somehow was still being persecuted you
know for literally doing nothing wrong
and somehow all
that what's the guy's name
bad guy
bad guy from maritusa oh strogabor
strike a board guy with the beard
yeah yeah yeah uh with striga board with
him
he just met he like completely violates
her and then
take it to the council and then the
second later the look he's got a point
yeah
he do
and she's already stripped of her powers
she literally gave up everything for
this battle
and then it's it is cool to see like oh
wow in your next episode or third
episode just
now she's switching sides
against the people that she fought
against
it is it is a challenging prospect for
audiences to go on a journey like this
but they all
seem like the men at the the high tables
were all like freaking awful awful
people but i found you nilfgaard is not
exactly going to be quite ideal either
it was a
but you know he's not the only what's uh
lenny kraft's name uh
yeah with this dread him defecting sides
was actually interesting too you know
like
you don't know really what to trust and
and would i think it would be cool if
you do pull out that veil and see that
there was a gray there that we just
didn't see and perhaps that's why in
season one you never really spend time
with nilfgaard directly to show you that
oh this was really just a
um
a challenge a battle of perspectives and
not really that they were
these terrible humans
you know they might be propaganda they
did start you know they'd go on a war
and they kind of just uh
dominate lands and attack villages and
that's right so remember when they were
launching
which nukes yeah yeah that's true they
were making one which uh mages you know
turned into energy bombs people it's
regular people
yeah
but that's war for you man wars war sign
up get drafted
travel the world meet interesting people
and kill them
um
yeah so good [ __ ] though and i think
like the way they they've been
handling juggling a bunch of different
tones here you know you got one
that is like the uprising of siri
and um in a much different landscape and
a much different tone that has this
almost all awe-inspiring effect to it
and a more calamity towards the
situation
and then you got this like
chaos political more supernatural
enhanced sometimes breaking into
straight-up horror
with whether it be the visions of the
old women of the old woman
or
um you know yennefer being imprisoned
and tortured that side they're very
different
stories they're telling
but
you can't see how the one day they will
coalesce but weirdly enough it's like i
feel like in the prior season i might
have been like yeah it's all about the
yennefer stuff but if i had a preference
i would say actually it is the
geralt and siri storyline there's
something just more endearing about it i
guess you know yeah and it's really
gratifying because in the first season i
think and watching this so close to the
first season one of i think the
complaints you can kind of levy is that
like siri does a lot of running around
and running away from stuff but
that's just a real character but yeah
it's a lot of like oh we cut her for
like a scene and then most of the rest
of the year
whereas now you're actually like super
invested both in her but also her
relationship with geralt the rest of the
witchers and and even that like i i
liked the gradual way they played that
where it's like okay these witchers like
yeah they're not open to her but they're
also not bad guys because when she's
proving herself everyone's like hell
yeah let's do this yeah yeah so yeah
there's like a fraternal quality and
yeah it's always fun to watch someone
you know prove themselves and it is nice
they went down that path right i don't
know how the rest of it's going to
progress but i was like oh man is this
thing going to be like siri is going to
be the thing that tears geralt's apart
from his brothers
and then to take this other path or
they're like oh no they're all bonding
when they're good yeah this is much
better and from what i gather like
people didn't love the handling of eskel
and and karemoran in general in the last
episode so i'm curious about this one
but yeah i i exactly because i was like
oh no is this going to be the wedge that
means we got to leave here now
um and i'm sure they'll find a reason to
leave care more in sooner or later but
when winter is done yeah
we're not done chilling or done rusting
yeah yeah yeah but you know they say
there's there's a lot uh there's a lot
of mayhem that could befall them even
when they're trying to rest that's what
you think
yeah it's gonna be a chill season
but yeah i i especially appreciate that
they didn't go that route and at least
from this vantage point seeming as
though we are going to spend more time
to care more and i do like that yeah
it's not just like a random stuff we're
gonna make just to acknowledge it was
there in the stories and then the books
and all that it feels like a real place
that we get to inhabit yeah that's a
part of the life of geralt you know and
it is cool to see it like realized too
in the animated movie i'm sure in other
mediums
maybe the books had photos it was just
two illustrations
but to see it brought to life he had
photos from the real camera that wasn't
real wasn't this a real place no it
wasn't
i know waitress were real but karen
moore was rich
anyway guys
what did you think about this episode
leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button oh yeah we should shout out some
patrons who are pledged to a special
tier name call out time kick it off john
jason dolan
dolan jason's irish eva drasticova
supernova chase gardner wearing garters
natalie doran caught snorin disgusting
it's melanie leblanc o'clock
it took you 20 seconds to come up with
yeah
top 10 jen smith philip justice smith jr
my heart has fallen for colin rosie
beatty let's go ice skating justin
martin always farting sj94 what do you
got in store row cree i drink your pee
melissa gunterman except no other man
banana joanna saint louise i'd eat you
up like a fruit
he'd make a great leader that peter
pacheco never feel jaded by simply faded
lauren american horse is the source of
all my joy in life you know my motto the
jedi bro before ho
sean don's in for the long con
levitt odell is on a highway to hell
chasmatize patton differently sane is
unusually in pain olivia what a dull guy
kathleen with the greatest spleen mayor
thank you all for pledging
i'm sure we made it well worth it this
is what you waited for
all month merry christmas
[Music]
you